-You guys, I want to
say congrats to the
New York Yankees,
who are moving on
to the American League
Championship Series.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And congrats to the Mets,
who are moving on to binge-watch
season 8 of "Friends."
That's fantastic.
Yeah, you could tell the Yankees
were feeling good
when they popped champagne
lit cigars,
and it was only
the second inning.
That's when I knew
something was up.
Let's get to some news.
Today, the White House
stopped an important ambassado
from testifying.
Yep, Trump told his staff
to do whatever it takes
to stop anyone
from saying anything
that could endanger
his presidency.
And his staff was like, "Okay,
and duct taped his mouth shut.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Can't stop my Twitter hands."
"Get his hands, too!
Get his thumbs!
Tape his thumbs.
He has Twitter thumbs."
"Tweet!"
That's right.
The White House blocked ou
E.U. Ambassador Gordon Sondlan
from testifying
about the Ukraine scandal.
Because nothing says we've got
nothing to hide like saying,
"We got to hide Gordon."
Can we see what Gordon Sondlan
looks like?
Yeah.
Looks like an accountant
for the Addams family.
[ Laughter ]
He looks like a guy
who rents a Ferrari
for his high school reunion.
You know that guy?
He looks like a lawyer
who claims he only collect
money if you get paid.
You know?
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
"And I only take money
if you get paid."
Weak figure.
Apparently, the Ambassador
has a bunch of text messages
about Ukraine,
but the State Department
won't give them to Congress.
When she heard that,
Hillary Clinton was like,
"Russia, if you're listen,
I hope you're able to find
the texts
on the Ambassador's phone.
Oh, and get this -- I hear
that when the whistle-blower
testifies before Congress,
they might disguise
his appearance and his voice
which means there's
a good chance the Presiden
is about to be brought dow
by guy dressed as a Minion
[ Laughter ]
"Banana!"
And I read that, since the
impeachment inquiry began,
White House officials
have been dodging interviews
about the Ukraine scandal.
Apparently, they even got
their own excuse generator
to come up with reasons
why they can't talk.
I'll show you how it works
For example, when they asked
Attorney General William Bar
for an interview,
he said...
[ Electronic beeping ]
..."I would, but I'm working
as a John Goodman impersonator."
-Oh.
Well...
[ Applause ]
-Next, when they asked
Senator Rand Paul, he said..
[ Electronic beeping ]
..."I can't move the appointment
for my perm."
-Makes sense.
-You got to keep it tight.
-Yeah.
-Got to keep it tight!
Tight! Tight!
-Tight!
-Next, when they asked
Housing Secretary Ben Carson
he said...
[ Electronic beeping ]
..."I'm busy practicing fo
'Dancing with the Stars.'"
-Oh, well, yeah.
-That's going to be good.
-Valid excuse.
-And, finally,
when they asked Rudy Giuliani --
Look at that picture.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God!
-When they asked Rudy Giuliani
for an interview, he said...
[ Electronic beeping ]
..."Sorry, I'm having
a colonoscopy as we speak.
Wow!
-"As we speak."
-Wow.
-Something's up.
-Now, today, Trump had lunch
with Vice President Mike Pence
You can tell Trump's
paranoid about leaks
because, before the meeting,
he frisked Pence
to see if he was wearing a wire.
He's like "Wow, you're lik
a Ken doll everywhere."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
"Mother? Mother, get in here."
Did you guys see this?
China is refusing
to broadcast NBA games
after the Houston Rockets' G
spoke out
in support
of Hong Kong's protesters.
It's a bad situation
'cause the NBA needs China
to grow their fan base
and to make their shoes.
-Yeah.
[ Audience groans ]
-It's true, it's true.
It's true.
-Yeah.
-Let's face facts.
-Hey, listen to this.
To save taxpayer money,
the king of Sweden
just took away royal statu
from five of his grandkids
For us, it's a news story.
For Eric and Don Jr.,
it's a preview.
Get this -- a British man
became the first person
to fly around the world
in a gyrocopter.
Yep. When asked to comment
on his flight in a gyrocopter,
he said, "Actually,
it's pronounced yeero-copter
[ Laughter ]
Probably...
-Didn't know that.
-Probably didn't know that
A little over your head.
So, no big deal.
-Needs to spin.
-It's just, my family they'v
always flown in yeero-copters.
That's what you call it.
So...no big deal.
-Yeah.
-And finally, a French tow
made a world record
setting fruit salad that weighed
almost 23,000 pounds.
When they heard about wastin
23,000 pounds of fruit,
Edible Arrangements was like
"Stay in your lane, girl."
We have a great show.